NASA, is not only the world's
premier space exploration agency,
it's also one of the most recognisable
brands in history. It plays a prominent
role in countless films and TV shows, and
its various iconic logos and insignias can
be seen on everything from
hot water bottles to hoodies.
Just saying the acronym - NASA - conjures
images of chiselled-jawed astronauts posing
beneath shining rocket ships; assorted super
geniuses huddling around computer screens;
and a random woman giving a
dolphin a handjob... wait, what?
For all NASA's undeniable excellence, over
the years this storied organisation has had
the odd mishap. Like the time the 300
million dollar Mars Climate Orbiter was
lost because one of its software systems
used metric units and another imperial.
Embarrasingly, nobody even noticed until it
hit Mars' atmosphere, and immediately exploded.
But there’s been no blunder more bonkers
than the batshit-crazy dolphin project that
NASA funded in the 1960s. In fact, forget
NASA - this might just be the most absurd
experiment in the history of modern
science, involving interspecies sex,
drugs, and a woman living in a flat
share with a dolphin called Peter.
So, buckle up your seat belt and strap
on your snorkel for the titillating tale
of the NASA experiment that went so
wrong it ended up in a porn magazine.
Considering just how bad things got - and we're
talking 'injecting dolphins with LSD' bad - the
project had its origins in some genuinely
groundbreaking science - being the brainchild
of a rising star in the fields of psychoanalysis
and neuroscience by the name of Dr. John Lilly.
Lilly was one of the first scientists
to put serious effort into understanding
animal intelligence. His early work
largely concerned cats and dogs,
but it soon became clear that if he wanted to
find true intelligence in the animal kingdom,
he was going to have to study creatures
with brains as large and complex as our own.
The bottlenose dolphin proved the perfect
choice. Not only do they do well in captivity,
their brains are actually bigger
than a human's by about 30%,
and their brain to bodyweight ratio,
while smaller than ours, is larger
than a chimpanzee's and similar to that of our
human ancestors from around 2 million years ago.
That's an eye opening stat, and it led John Lilly
to suspect that dolphins might not
just be 'intelligent for animals',
but intelligent full stop - with
cognitive abilities approaching our own.
In the late 1950s, he set out to prove it,
and it was during a pioneering study into
dolphin intelligence that Lilly made a startling
discovery. Or to be more specific, his wife did.
She'd been hanging out by one of the
dolphin pools, discussing some test
results with another researcher, when one of
the dolphins nearby appeared to be mimicking
the sounds of their voices... it was almost as
though it wanted to join in the conversation.
Lilly was already convinced dolphins were
extremely intelligent, and as far as he was
concerned, the fact that his own test subjects
were trying to talk to him was the strongest
proof yet. Excited about the implications, he
switched the focus of his research from studying
animal intelligence generally to the more radical
goal of directly communicating with dolphins.
The idea that we might be able to have an
actual conversation with another species was so
groundbreaking it was picked up by the mainstream
media. Lilly made TV and radio appearances,
and in 1961 he published his research so far
in a book called Man and Dolphin. But this was
more than just a recap of his experiments -
it included Lilly's speculative visions for a
future in which fluent English-speaking dolphins
might one day have a seat at the United Nations.
That might sound pretty mental. I mean, it
*is* pretty mental. But Lilly's book got quite
a lot of important people really rather excited,
including legendary astrophysicist Frank Drake.
If you're a regular follower of the channel,
that name will already be familiar to you.
Drake is most famous today for the equation
that bears his name - a mathematical formula
that attempts to predict the number of advanced
civilizations in our galaxy - and he was convinced
John Lilly's work on dolphin communication was
extremely relevant to his own. Why, you ask?
Well, in 1960, less than a year before
John Lilly published Man and Dolphin,
Frank Drake kicked off mankind's as yet
incomplete side quest to find intelligent
life in space when he completed the first
modern search for aliens, known as Project
Ozma. But he wasn't simply interested in
*finding* aliens - he wanted to make contact.
But how on earth do you even attempt
to communicate with an alien race
whose experiences, culture, and language
are so incredibly different to your own?
You can probably see where this is going -
Drake saw trying to talk to dolphins as a
practice run for first contact with aliens. So
he spoke to his contacts at NASA who promptly
decided that the space race could wait,
so a man called John could have tea and
biscuits with a god-damn dolphin - and sure
enough, they wrote him a massive cheque..
The influx of cash allowed Lilly to build himself
a villa on the idyllic Caribbean island of St.
Thomas. But this was no swanky holiday home - the
nondescript exterior hid a top secret lab that
Lilly hoped would soon be the site of one of the
greatest scientific achievements in human history.
The villa was directly on the coast,
with office space upstairs and a
pool below that was replenished with
seawater every time the tide came in.
It was named Dolphin Point and finished in late
1963, by which point Lilly had assembled a crack
team of top scientists to begin working on his
dream of direct human-dolphin communication.
A few months into the project, a young local woman
by the name of Margaret Howe Lovatt turned up at
the lab out of the blue. Small islands are
difficult places on which to keep secrets,
and Margaret had been intrigued by rumours of a
mysterious lab where humans and dolphins lived
in close proximity. Caribbean island, secret lab,
dolphin pool - personally I'd have assumed it was
the lair of a Bond villain and stayed well
away, but Margaret had Dr. No such qualms.
On arrival at the lab, rather than being gunned
down by a nameless goon, she was invited inside
to see the dolphins for herself. She spent
the entire day there, observing the animals
and jotting down extensive notes that she
shared with the team later that evening.
Margaret was a woman of just 22 with no normal
formal training as a naturalist, but she'd made
some genuinely insightful comments about the
dolphins and their behaviour. So insightful,
in fact, that she was offered a job on the spot.
And not just any job - Lilly ultimately assigned
her what was arguably the most important -
and controversial - role on the entire team:
Margaret was going to teach
the dolphins to speak English.
It was, to put it lightly, a big ask. If you
happen to be an especially observant individual,
you've probably already noticed
that humans and dolphins are quite
different. Even if dolphins *were* capable
of understanding the English language - and
that was obviously a pretty big 'if' -
there were some serious physiological
challenges to overcome if they were
ever going to actually speak it.
Unlike us humans, dolphins don't have
vocal cords. They don't even 'speak'
with their mouths - above water they make
sound in a similar way to most politicians:
by forcing air out of their blowholes.
There were 3 dolphins at the
Dolphin Point lab - Sissy, Pamela,
and Peter. Margaret worked almost exclusively
with Peter - he was the youngest of the 3, and,
unlike the females he was entirely untrained by
humans, which made him something of a blank slate.
To begin with, his lessons went
spectacularly well. While he wasn't
able to form recognisable words, he *was*
able to reliably imitate Margaret's speech
patterns and inflection. That might
not sound like much, but Peter had,
in a couple of weeks, mastered something that
would have taken a human child several years.
Margaret was spending every minute
of her waking life at the lab,
but it wasn't enough. Every second spent separated
from Peter was a second they would never get back,
and when she left the lab and went home for
the night, it emphasised the simple fact that,
no matter how much time they spent together,
she and Peter lived in very different worlds.
As far as Margaret was concerned, that was
a big problem, and she came up with a truly
radical solution in order to overcome it.
If she was going to bridge the gap between
man and dolphin, she had to tear down the
natural barriers that stand between us.
With Lilly's permission, she had the entire
first floor of the lab waterproofed and
flooded with thigh-deep seawater. She then
installed all sorts of unusual furniture,
including a desk that hung down from
the ceiling and a bed that stood on
a raised platform. By the time the
unusual renovations were complete,
Lilly and Margaret had created the world's first
- and probably last - dolphin-human flat share.
For the following six months, Margaret lived
there with Peter 24 hours a day, 7 days a week.
Despite the radical change in living
circumstances, Peter's progress,
so promising to begin with, slowed to a
crawl. He was extremely adept at mimicking
sounds and he understood a wide range of simple
instructions. But his ability to use the English
language - or even form recognisable
words - was going absolutely nowhere.
Not long after Margaret and Peter shacked up
together, NASA sent Carl Sagan to see how their
money was being spent on St. Thomas. (Yeah,
*that* Carl Sagan). Unfortunately Sagan wasn't
particularly impressed with what he saw. He was
convinced Peter was simply mimicking the sounds
Margaret was making, with limited - if any -
understanding of what those sounds actually meant.
Worried that things were getting out of hand,
Drake and Sagan attempted to realign the focus
of Lilly's work. Recognising that teaching
dolphins to speak English was likely to remain
firmly in the realm of science fiction rather
than science future, they recommended Lilly
turn his attention to better understanding
how dolphins communicate with one another.
The astrophysicists had some pretty
good ideas as to how to do it, too.
For example, Drake had come up with a clever
experiment to test whether dolphins could
communicate complex ideas to one another through
language alone. It worked by separating two
dolphins so that they could hear but not see
each other. One dolphin would be shown how to
obtain food by following a seemingly random set
of instructions. If the second dolphin suddenly
started following the same procedure despite
having never been shown it by his handlers,
it would demonstrate advanced
communication capabilities.
But that wasn't enough for Lilly.
Proving dolphins had language of
their own would be interesting,
but opening up a genuine line of
communication with a non-human species
would cement his place in history.
And so Margaret's lessons with Peter continued,
but they weren't without their issues.
As a young male dolphin in the process of reaching
sexual maturity, Peter had certain... needs. And
it turns out horny dolphins find it almost
impossible to concentrate on their lessons,
something I'm sure every schoolboy can relate to.
By this point in the experiment Peter
had grown extremely attached to Margaret,
and when he was feeling particularly fruity,
he'd start to rub himself up against her legs,
giving her what I suppose you'd have to call a
good old wet humping. To begin with, Margaret
solved this issue by giving Peter some time
with the two female dolphins in the pool below.
But the process of transferring Peter between
the lab and the pool was a tricky one,
requiring lots of time, several
people, and a makeshift lift.
Precious hours were lost to the
complex manoeuvre, so to save time
Margaret decided to take matters into her own
hands. And by 'matters' I mean Peter's penis.
Whenever he grew distracted by
thoughts of porpoise-based porn,
she would manually stimulate him to orgasm,
at which point their lessons could continue.
Despite the focused flat share tutelage and
regular hand shandys, Peter's progress had
stalled. His ability to mimic Margaret's voice
was better than ever, but he still wasn't able
to form words, and he was nowhere near being able
to use language to communicate thoughts or ideas.
Margaret wasn't worried - she was convinced they
were on the cusp of a breakthrough - if only she
could molest Flipper - I mean Peter - a few more
times, then he’d soon be a seaborn Shakespeare.
But Dr. Lilly saw things differently. By ignoring
the advice of Frank Drake and Carl Sagan he'd
ruffled a few feathers at NASA. He needed
concrete results, and he needed them fast.
The swinging sixties are synonymous with
hippie culture, and between them Margaret
Howe and Peter the dolphin had certainly
given new meaning to the words 'free love.'
But as Dr. John Lilly grew more and more
desperate to demonstrate tangible progress,
he turned to another of the 60s defining
symbols for inspiration - mind-altering drugs.
In a lovely little coincidence, it was the wife
of Ivan Tors, producer of Flipper the Dolphin,
who first introduced John Lilly to
LSD. And over the course of the 60s,
the study (and taking) of Acid began to overtake
his interest in dolphins altogether. But
as Peter reached his language plateau,
Lilly realised there might be a way to bring
these two very different research areas together.
LSD wasn't just being used by tie-dye tosspots in
tents to get tit-faced, it was also being trialled
for all sorts of weird and wonderful applications,
from curing mental illness to mind control.
Having run dozens of LSD 'experiments' on himself,
Lilly knew all too well that it had the ability
to expand the mind and encourage new experiences.
In attempting to teach a dolphin to speak
English, Lilly was trying to touch the
mind of another species. He figured a
little LSD might help bridge the divide,
and so he dosed both the dolphins
- and himself - with the drug.
If you're picturing dolphins lying on their
backs contemplating the stars swirling above
with huge grins on their faces, you are
- thankfully - mistaken. Despite several
attempts, the dolphins showed no sign
of being affected by the drugs. Still,
the dose proved fatal for the experiment
as a whole. Several prominent members
of the research team promptly quit, and
Lilly's funding was cut shortly afterwards.
I'd love to say our story ends there, but
unfortunately one final tragic chapter remains.
The experiment may have been over, but while
Margaret, Lilly, and the rest of the research team
could simply go home and move on with their lives,
the fate of the three dolphins was far less clear.
In the end, they were transported to a
small lab in a converted bank in Miami.
Conditions there were truly awful
- the dolphins were kept in tiny,
chlorine-filled tanks that were too
small to swim in, and there was no
natural light. Even more importantly - at
least for Peter - there was no Margaret.
We can't speak to dolphins - Lilly's experiment
proved that. But you didn't need to chat to Peter
to know he'd fallen in love with Margaret.
When the experiment ended she was taken away
from him for reasons he didn't understand,
and he never recovered from the heartbreak.
A few weeks after his arrival in Miami, he sank
to the bottom of his tiny tank and stayed there,
refusing to rise to the surface to take a breath
for several long minutes until he was dead.
Animal suicide is a controversial topic.
To truly call Peter's death suicide,
we need to be sure he had a solid grasp
of abstract concepts like life and death,
as well as an understanding that his
actions would ultimately kill him.
But whether or not you choose to call it suicide,
soon after John Lilly's experiment concluded and
Margret went away, Peter the dolphin was no more.
After Margaret got over her grief, she ended up
marrying the experiment's official photographer.
They were allowed to move into the Dolphin
Point lab where Margaret had lived so happily
with Peter. Luckily her new husband didn't find it
weird to live in the same house as his wife's ex,
and the happy couple went on to raise
three children there. The lab was never
fully converted into a family home, and remained
partly flooded until they eventually moved out.
As for Lilly, he fell pretty deep down the LSD
rabbit hole, becoming something of a counter
culture guru in the swinging 60s and beyond.
For a couple of decades at least, he was more
drug-addict than scientist. Earlier in his career
he invented the sensory deprivation tank - you
know, that thing Eleven gets into so she can use
her remote viewing powers in Stranger Things.
Lilly mostly used his personal tank to heighten
his trips when taking drugs like LSD and Ketamine.
And it was during one of those journeys
into his own mind that he became convinced
the world was being manipulated by something
called the Earth Coincidence Control Office.
I started this video by talking about
an acronym - NASA - and I'm going to end
it in the same way. If you're old enough to
have played Megadrive games back in the 90s,
the Earth Coincidence Control Office, or 'ECCO,'
will almost certainly sound familiar to you.
'ECCO' the Dolphin was a surprise
smash hit on Sega's all-conquering
console. Few people who played the game
ever knew about the strange man - and
the even stranger experiments - that inspired it.
Lilly's NASA funded dolphin experiment was largely
forgotten about after its conclusion - that is,
until it appeared in an issue of Hustler in
the late 1970s. Titled 'Interspecies Sex:
Humans and Dolphins,' the piece was pure
filth, and there was a public outcry about
the things that had been done to Peter
and his pals in the name of science.
Most NASA-funded experiments end up
in scientific journals. The fact that
this was one found its way into a porn
magazine certainly wasn't ideal as far as
John Lilly and Margret Lovatt were concerned,
but it did help cement this strange story’s
place in the history books as one of the
most outrageous experiments of all time.
So long, and thanks for all the fish..